[Music]
back in the building back on the map lef
koe and Westbrook in a sec what oh yeah
my my headphones cut out yeah yeah I
lost my musics yeah yeah no to be honest
Westbrook and I were talking about the
Eagles Fiasco's because it happens is
when you drop two three and four gets
shellacked on national television and
there's a brewing controversy about who
is complaining publicly or hiding behind
who's the snitch
who's the snitch who's the guy telling
all the inside information in the locker
room who was that guy man all right
we're gonna get to that in a second
I promise we won't spend the whole
podcast on that we have shark tank
excuse me
dolphin tank contain we have a new game
called jinx game and I have no idea how
it's gonna go but I'm excited we will
talk about some of the disappointing
games the crazy weeks as you can see
behind Westbrook was one of the most
incredible visual visual things I've
seen this time Niners Washington game it
was just slip and slides how do you feel
get that win I mean I've never been to
own a field that wet that field had
standing water I mean that's usually the
fields have drainage you know they cover
the field
NASA's the same field that fell apart
and we saw rg3 get really hurt they
caught like a sand pit and like I guess
that Washington field must be like the
worst drainage seal in the NFL game
Snyder has a bunch of money he should
have put some money towards fixing that
field because that's that can't be safe
but I loved it I mean it looked really
really I hated it because I took San
Fran same yeah I hated that to her you
hated it
San Francisco could've won that game by
40 they should have but I made the rain
and and the one thing I want to note
just a little some upcoming schedules
this when's - there will only be two
podcast this week we will not have a
roundtable podcast one Brian has some
family stuff and then also I am flying
and I'm getting ready to go to London
Wow
yeah just a trip man so we're going
go to London it's gonna be me and the
stick to football guys okay Connor
Rogers and Matt Miller we're gonna be on
Sunday at O'Neill's on Carnaby Street in
London just check out left coast show
Instagram or Twitter and I I smoked the
daddy cigar and then made a Photoshop of
myself in London if you were like
there's no legs who did this edit I'm
like it was me shut the [ __ ] up
but at 4 o'clock we're gonna kind of do
a joint podcast and then I'm gonna we're
gonna try and bring some some American
football habits to London okay
apparently they don't sit in bars and
watch football and son what do they do
they just don't do it today don't watch
football at all they do it might be in
their own home but like they'll do this
more for world football like Chelsea vs.
Manchester City and I'm saying let's
keep it rolling apparently there's a big
match on Sunday let's hang out drink
some tequila
just keep board is that a drink there
eat some shitty food yeah I shouldn't
insult them should I go eat their chips
and fish and chips it and chips there oh
no I almost said crikey yeah I thought
come and kick it O'Neill's on Carnaby
Street and then I think we're gonna
release the sharp the Warren Sharpe
podcast on the Thursday this week so it
won't come out a Friday might come on
Thursday but that's coming up so Sunday
O'Neill's in Carnaby Street it should be
great I hope that's how you say that is
Warren Sharpe the smartest guy you know
I mean especially football around around
the game I mean he says some things you
like no then you look at the statue like
okay at the same point like when he was
so sure that it was gonna be the over
449 Seahawks Ravens and it was and then
the Seahawks kicked that [ __ ] field
goal dude I had some really bad betting
experience it was bad weekend for you
there's bad weekend for me too so I had
Bears over to under-20 and a half uh-huh
and they had ten points until like four
it was then it turned it up a little
oh I mean I'm just yelling I you know
we're like you you you're doing so
poorly on betting that you stop yelling
you just quietly pack up your thing yeah
yeah the game is over I don't my
experience is over I'm out I don't want
to say anything else I stressed eat so
much
I want your diet your diet Sunday's are
my worse than Sunday's you're cheating
Mondays
Tuesdays Wednesdays I'm feeling great
Thursdays I end up getting wings but I
don't get a lot of he's making a mistake
then Sunday's I come here and my bets go
to [ __ ] and I just start eating yogurt
covered pretzels handfuls of yeah the
occasional fruit snack that's no good I
had a whole pack of gummy bears
yesterday and I don't I'm not supposed
to be there giggles yeah I just I just
swallowed them just come on mouth and
try my best to chew me not even thinking
about it just ate oh yeah it was so
absurd just looking for happiness
comfort food that's that's what I do
Comfort yeah and these last few weeks I
think I went two and three in the super
contest and I lost San Francisco
I lost Seattle - new team and I lost I
think I had the I think the Giants I did
- yeah did I get my bets from you no but
I do get minute I did get Minnesota and
I didn't get Jacksonville had a terrible
week all right so let's let then let's
get a little happy yeah doing our
favorite segment Oh coach is dolphin
dolphin tank okay so you've bought some
interesting things last week you burped
you bought Kirk Cousins and it looks
great hauling ball right now
Paulin you know you know why because the
Eagles pissed them off they talk bad
about him and now he's just doing his
thing yeah Kirk Cousins in a dome
against bad passing defense that's right
make sure all right but let's get to the
new dolphin tank pitches this week let's
toss it over to our disembodied voice
David Inger
welcome back to Dolphin tank where Lefko
pitches venture capitalist Brian
Westbrook on some of his new NFL
investments first up left goes got a
tough 10 defense that you need to buy
right now
that's right it's now or never Brian
Westbrook if you don't purchase it we're
gonna move on to somewhere else no team
has scored more than 20 points against
this defense all season hmm their 10th
against the past 12 against the run
their top five in points allowed per
game their top ten and sex I have to get
rid of them now are you interested in
buying them so they're top ten top ten
in sex what do the offense look like the
offense is average to below average but
I'm only selling you the defense you're
not buying the off and you're getting
rid of it I would say the offense had a
little bit more excitement this week cuz
they score some more points they just
looked better they look better but every
day we came out this think about this
they did win this weekend but think
about this this their offense has not
played well but the defense has still
never allowed anyone to score over 20
points in the game so think about it
this isn't some team it's just yeah oh I
will I'll buy that thank God I had to
get him out of here do you want to guess
it who it is the Broncos hmm it is the
Titans the Titan how about that nasty
defense they do have a very nasty
defense Titans top ten in sacks and top
five in points allowed I went back they
have not allowed over 20 points in any
game this year really which is pretty
wild and these are right here and for
accents I think the Titans right now are
three and four yes yeah so they go when
they play the Chargers yesterday and it
was and today looked okay yesterday and
that's why I say it's a little bit more
interesting yeah Tannehill is a
defensive coordinators dream mm-hmm he's
gonna he's gonna go like 24 or 29 but
the problem with Tannehill is he also
fumbles a lot when he gets sacked very
inconsistent and just like kind of
leaves the ball up I thought what was
really cool was that their first-round
pick that had an ACL tear that was
during the during the the combine all
that Justin Simmons played and
had a sack had a few tackles for losses
it was very impressive but I came
everyone comes away this game leaving
talking about how the Chargers blew it
and how the Chargers are so
disappointing right and I look at the
Titans and I go I still don't know if
this team is good or not I don't think
they're good no they're not good I mean
you got to also think about that
division
you got the Texas in there which I told
you they're gonna lose so that the Colts
and they did the Colts who've been
playing I didn't tell you that I picked
him pretty sure I pick the colors anyway
we were picking teams we're talking
about the best team in the division yeah
and I picked the Colts I picked the
coach you picked the text I did not that
was absolution you picked the text we'll
play devil's advocate yes oh yeah well
you pick the Texas anyway in that
division it's gonna be just hard to
compete I mean yeah you got some teams
that are really really good the coach do
a great job of protecting the
quarterback I love that but offensively
the Texans I mean the Titans just aren't
gonna be good enough they love to run
the football no consistency at the
quarterback position if you don't have
that in this league and your defense
I mean if let's just say you have no
consistency at the quarterback position
that means your defense has to get you
the ball back and score they can't do
that consistently over game after game
at the game I'm really happy that I was
able to sell the Titans I mean if you
think about it but like this a team that
went to Atlanta what Atlanta was firing
how them 210 but they've also played the
last few weeks the bills and the Broncos
but I'm glad I got rid of them they
still have the Chiefs coming up please
don't play the Texans so I think you
bought a property that might lose value
but that's my stance it stinks okay
you did give me any information on the
offense that's the most important part
defense is good yeah but alright let's
get to the second part of dolphin tank
next into the tank left goes hoping
Westbrook will buy in on the best pass
rusher that nobody's talking about
that's right not his friends not his
high school coach not the local
newspaper from the town he grew up in
and not even as family
not one person is talking about this guy
so who is it hmm
this is a guy as you cheat and look up
statistics no cheating no cheating I got
I got a look at the teams I have them
all in my head on which this guy is well
on his way to his fifth double-digit
sacks season in a row okay he's top five
in the NFL in sacks right now okay
he has no help on this D line not a
single defensive end on his team has
more than a sack and this guy is in top
five right now and no one's talking
about him would you buy this pass rusher
that no one's talking about would I buy
a pass rusher that is top five I'm
telling you I mean if that's just the
premise would I buy a top five pass
rusher absolutely that and I think the
thing is is that um he is this is now
I'm not trying to sell you low here I'm
trying to educate people that this
[ __ ] balls listen if you have
it this is the thing stopping the
quarterback yeah is the number one thing
in football yes in order to do that you
have to have a cornerback that's why
Jalen Ramsay's about to get beat be paid
I'll see you in LA but in its pass
rusher but there are but there are every
year there are some pass rushers that
have won big game and an influence right
but the reason that I have I have so
much love for this guy's he's downs out
of five seasons in a row he's consist
you wanna guess and who it is um you
might get this one five seats so he's
still a young kid right still young I
would say upper 20s hold up I like is it
hunter from the Vikings no but I love
Daniel hunter he's really really good
alright so the answer is Chandler Jones
Chandler Jones has been bald in County
nine quietly because nobody watches the
Cardinals that's right last three games
he's had a half a sack or more in every
game against the Giants
four sacks on Sunday wow that's that's
I've forced more forced fumbles but what
I'm saying though is is we've we've seen
this with other guys like we talked
about Shaquille Barrett and Sheila
really hasn't had a sack these last few
weeks but Chandler Jones has been a
model of consistency ever since he came
from New England I think in the 55 games
he's played in Arizona he's had forty
nine and a half sacks
he does it every year he has no help on
this defensive lose opposite of Suggs
when the Cardinals right now are three
three and one and I think it's been a
mix of Kyler Murray who's been
phenomenal this running game whether
it's been Edmonds Kyler whose run more
games and David Johnson who came out and
then Edmonds were still able to do it
this is not a great offensive line no
but I look at they just get Patrick
Peterson that's huge
that's huge for huge for this pass for
Chandler Jones but I look at Chandler
and I go he's always been a guy when he
has a mash up that he can win he wins
dominates yeah and I love the Cardinals
right now I think they're super fun to
watch I think they are fun to watch I
think their quarterback is a big part of
that but when you get Patrick Peterson
back you add a depth there that makes
your quarterback hold the ball a little
bit long oh it makes you second-guess if
you want to throw that interception or
take the sack that that kind of bodes
well for Chandler Jones but I think the
siting part about this offense is that
you got a couple guys in the backfield
that can get it done Johnson and Edmonds
Edmonds Heelys looks faster yeah than
everybody else he looks so much quicker
so much faster and also by the way did
you know he went to Fordham yeah it's
it's like I don't know if there's like a
secret society of Fordham but like
whenever someone goes to Fordham
everyone's like by the way you know we
went to Fordham get this weird New York
thing yeah cuz nobody expects good
football players to come from for them
yeah nobody expects that but I think
there is I just feel like we don't talk
about the fact that Tirico went to like
North Carolina A&T this feel like every
time I hear or taste em and it's Fordham
and I don't want to play the game
Siciliano did like a million times
yesterday really yeah the Fordham game
yeah Fordham grads are interesting it's
right they're really really smart beaten
us I think went to Fordham 50 grid I
nights Dennis seems like a really cool
guy I don't even know if that's true I
may have made that I think he'd sit for
it him
no sir he said for him he didn't it's
true yes there yeah he seemed like a
Fordham guy though
so here's one thing I like about
Arizona's often since we're talking
about chase Edmunds who went to Fordham
the rest of the team so the first four
weeks of the year the Cardinals ran for
wide receivers
sixty four point two percent of the time
this was the offense that Kliff
Kingsbury was going to bring in and then
what I think is amazing is the last
three weeks they've had four wide
receivers in the field 16 percent of the
time so it dropped 48 percent and for me
that gets me excited because as I've
said before even as great as Lamar
Jackson has been I still think Kyler is
the one of all these young guys that
might have the highest do you I realize
still stand by it it's it's his mobility
it's his touch on deep balls I think
Kyler is the next Russell Wilson I said
it last week I'll say it again he may be
more exciting than Russell Wilson
Russell Wilson is that old reliable Russ
we talked about just basic and plain I
don't know I just been so excited he has
been exciting because he saves the game
with his arm but Kyler is if you just
get him a little bit of space I mean
this kid is so fast in a small package
he makes plays that you don't think that
he'll be able to make in the arm yeah
arm talent is there but what excites me
is like we see a lot of young coaches
that come into the league and they want
to do it their way mm-hmm but what you
don't realize what the NFL is is you
need to adjust every single week that's
right and so the fact that cliff has
been able to adjust and Arizona over the
last three weeks has been one of the
best running teams the NFL and they're
really not doing it with a ton of
offensive line town or any wide receiver
talent is a testament to what that
relationship could be the other side
though that was very disappointed in
Daniel Jones
this is an Arizona defense that has been
destroyed by tight ends this year has
allowed a lot of big games and Daniel
Jones is holding on to the ball for way
too long especially when your offensive
lines getting destroyed
to throw he's scared to throw the ball
as I think Patrick Peterson played a big
part of that you know I think say Quan
had a good game I'm starting to wonder
if patch Surma is the right guy
listen lead this quarterback he called
in a na we need to go down the field and
score to tie or win this game there was
a third and 15 for Patrick Shermer
called
a draw play yeah and then it was like
fourth and 16 and then they threw for it
so I know that he was trying to get but
like don't be [ __ ] cute you don't
have to be stop no and you get evan
eager him back you gets a qualms it was
third and 18 he called a draw play you
have the opportunity to feed your horses
allow you guys to eat a little bit you
know what I still don't think say Quan
is all the way back I saw him become a
little gimpy there oh yeah I just a
little bit I just wonder if Pat is a guy
to lead and mold a young quarterback
yeah I think you put a quarterback you
put coaches in place before the talent
that they have right now and you hope
that they can mold younger talent
because of course you're gonna have that
younger talent coming in at some point
I'm not sure that he's the right guy to
lead this football team one into the
future yeah I don't know I still the
jury's still out I just think that it's
I don't want to blame it on Pat because
I know that if it was if he had the
choice daniel Jones would have a few
more games of experience course he would
and he'd be in a different stage I think
that Pat has kind of earned the right
with all the Gettleman nonsense and the
ownership meddling that I'm judging Pat
Sherman on how Daniel Jones looks at the
end of the year I want to see
development I want to see him build the
offense around have you seen the values
I was more upset yesterday with the
Giants run defense and how awful that
was just because they the Cardinals
could do whatever they wanted the Giants
defense has been bad for for a long time
yeah but schirmer's an offensive guy
yeah like I get on Dan Quinn because I
go oh bro you're the defense and your
defense looks like [ __ ] you have no you
have no leg to stand on we're with
Sherman I'm like hey James better can we
fix this defense really quick so bunch
of holes in that diesel but the fact
that Arizona right now is 3 3 & 1
are you surprised though know that it's
exciting to me because I thought they
were gonna be alive I'll say this I mean
we have to give everything context of
course winning
deserves tomboys the Falcons you talk
about the bangles the Falcons and a
giant I mean three bad teams by awful
teams at the same point the Bengals are
oh and seven yes and they've lost the
games too like Arizona and like other
shittier teams they're really bad made
they're really bad and and so my thing
is is that's the difference in this
league is the teams that go 12 and 4 win
like the Niners one where or the bills
one yesterday
yeah where you played like crap and you
somehow win the game and those are the
teams that win more than 10 games the
teams that go in the first pick of the
draft are the teams that when you play
the other shittier teams you [ __ ]
suck yeah like the Bengals are one of
the worst teams the NFL in turnover
margin Washington like consistently just
gives games away like fumbling those are
the teams end up in the bottom
everywhere else is mediocrity Ville and
to me that's the worst because I'd
rather be really shitty and get a top
five pick or amazing and go on the
playoffs but no one wants to be in that
middle and the middle is where you get
the Titans you know what I mean the
middle right now is where you're gonna
get the Chargers like that's where the
Chargers will end up in the middle but
for a team like the Cardinals who I
thought were gonna be a bottom five if
they end up in the middle I'm proud of
that season because they're a building
team that's not a team that I thought
would do anything this year we know that
you're right they are there's end up in
the middle it's disappointing
if the rams end up in the middle it's
disappointing expectations expectations
saying hey yeah you should be here and
you feel you ended up here and you're
not good enough in the middle
I'm happy for of course because no one
expected them to do well now the Falcons
ending up in that bottom groove is gonna
get their coach fires is what's gonna
happen and I'm surprised he hasn't
gotten fired already
right so I think there are some teams
where we kind of have certain
expectations and I just don't want to
forget what we thought these teams could
do in the beginning of the year as our
what about the Texas if the Texas don't
win their division in a division where
Andrew Luck is gone now right that's a
disappointment well to me it's a
disappointment I think that the the
division if if you're a Texan
right and I told you before the year
Nick Foles is gonna be out for an
extended period of time Andrew Luck is
gonna surprisingly retire before the
season and the Tennessee Titans are
gonna bench Marcus Mariota and yes seven
and you get yourself a left tackle that
you've been begging for and you get a
left tackle in Dwayne brown and Kenny
Stills but this is the thing is until
the Texans realize that Bill O'Brien
he's a problem is not the coach going
forward this is what they're always
going to get but to me I don't want to
blame the Texans I think more it's to
look at the Indianapolis Colts and to
celebrate the culture that they've built
this is a team that did not want Frank
Reich as their head coach they tried to
get josh mcdaniels they got strung along
they get their backup Chris Ballard
figures it out this is a team that had
the most money to spend in all the free
agency and barely spent anything their
starting quarterback surprisingly
retires weeks before the season starts
and this is an Indianapolis Colts team
that currently is sitting at the four
seed in the playoffs is four and two and
just want a monster game over the
Houston Texans to get a leadership in
the in the division we credible we
always talked about it
win in the trenches and they lost arias
Leonard for a few weeks
he came T Y Hilton's been hurt for a few
weeks it's unbelievable they win in the
trenches but Jacobi Bruce ed has been
really good because he's had a bunch of
time to throw the football they do a
great job of scheming up and saying hey
we're gonna block with the most people
we can if there's seven people eight
people were running a two-man route we
have no problem with that we're gonna
allow you the time to throw the football
down the field and percent has been
accurate he's been accurate he's taking
care of the football he's making big
plays down the field this is all that
you can ask from this young man
especially with the defense that's being
stingy you got a little bit of a run
game of Marlon Mac you're getting the
ball back to you offensively this is a
great setup for it 4% I was at an Eagles
watch party on Sunday now man and
someone we're not gonna transition to
this it's to make a point about you
girls and they said I don't understand
what's wrong with the offense it's still
Doug and I would say if you looked back
at
Eagle Super Bowl run and that offense
what team in the NFL is the closest to
running that offense and I'd say it's
the offensive coordinator of that Eagles
team Frank Reich in Indianapolis when I
watched the Colts offense I see what
Carson Wentz was running two years ago
with Ebron and Doyle and Mack and naheem
Hines and getting different running
backs involved an occasional deep shots
two wide receivers Frank Reich is
running that offense Frank Reich was
also running that offense with the
Chargers when Phillip Rivers was putting
up points yes so if you were to ask me
now and I i love Doug Peterson and I
can't believe I'm gonna say this don't
say it if the Eagles could have Frank
Reich or Doug Peterson as their head
coach or I would take Frank Reich of
course and Doug made some decisions and
has the analytic prowess but I don't
think Frank Reich doesn't have that if
he were the head coach during that run I
think that I look at the Eagles right
now and in that meeting room for the
offense is Doug Peterson might grow and
do Staley and it used to be Mike those
guys too but also Doug Peterson Frank
Reich and the do that is it that wasn't
in Jacksonville right now do you think
was it Minnesota and then that's the fan
ski he's still in Minnesota but I know
you talked about the hard part for John
D Phillip how do you feel about you but
yeah I think Frank Reich is Frank Reich
I think looking back now was the guy
that made that run happen and he's doing
it and he does a great job of he gets no
credit for skiing because you're talking
about all the young guys but he does a
great job of just putting theirs offense
they may listen I like I like to UI
Hilton I like Ebron but when you come
into the talk about the top five
receivers and Titans in the league you
probably don't mention those guys but
this game plan they scheme better than
anyone else and that's exactly what he
did for the Eagles he game-playing any
scheme better and right now what do you
do you protect your quarterback with the
run game you protect them with max
protection with the best offensive line
in football
period and you say we're gonna have some
time just go back
make it easy throw make the throw we're
gonna play 101 with our receivers gonna
allow them to win and make it easy throw
that's what we're said has done for four
touchdowns zero interceptions yesterday
I will say though though I know I was a
little hard on Houston I know will
feller has a hamstring injury
for a few weeks but the thing I will say
about the Texans is they are a team that
I think could end up still fighting in
the playoffs for the AFC because the AFC
right now is really weak right now if
the season was to end today which
obviously doesn't they would be the six
seed they're the they're the only there
are only six teams the AFC that have
four wins are better and there's eight
in the NFC but I look at Houston and
there was a point of that game where
they were down 28 to 13 with 638 left in
the fourth quarter and they came back
and were within I think five and we're
driving and it was a late interception
that ended it they also had a touchdown
taken away earlier in the game where
Shaun Watson was scrambling and they
called him down and he definitely wasn't
down they had a few very untimely
turnovers Houston's offense is good if
will fuller comes back is gonna keep
them in any game and they're in my mind
one of the most dangerous teams the NFL
but I value consistency and the Texans
don't have that and whenever I see a
team that's not consistent I usually
look at their coach and Bill O'Brien
fits that mold for me when you talk
about coaches you talk about penalties
ten penalties that's a lot of dog going
yards you giving up right there as far
as penalties these quarterbacks still
getting sacked your quarterbacks
throwing interceptions two interceptions
for Watson yesterday these are all
things that make you lose football games
especially against a team and the coach
that's not gonna make a bunch of
mistakes they're just not they're gonna
play solid offensively and aggressive
defensively they're not gonna make a
bunch of state mistakes the Texans have
always made mistakes they're always
making bad plays and that's why they
continue to lose games like this
especially inside of their own division
all right so we just went around the
entire NFL just realized we have another
dolphin do we let's do it
I love dolphin to ACTU the Dolph did I
buy that or no I did buy it pass from
did Chandler Jones yeah I'll take that
you're buying a lot today I'll buy that
rich and finally let go believes in one
particular NFC quarterback to lead his
team on a deep playoff run I don't mean
to sound cheesy but this guy's discount
double check downs lead to his team
driving down the field smoother than a
Lambo left go wants 12 percent of this
take in exchange for a spot on the
NASCAR circuit that's right you buy this
you get to be all NASCAR Brian Westbrook
ok this quarterback after a slow start
offensively whose team sitting
beautifully at six wins the last three
weeks he's put up just under 27 points
per game with a 108 points reading
yesterday this team won in a massacre
and he was missing some of his top
weapons will you buy this quarterback to
lead his team on a deep playoff run so
he's a good quarterback the team is six
- no no I said they have six wins six
wins okay
61 won I would assume that they I didn't
say that I just said they have six win
okay that's great to know under an 8.3
passer rating in the last three weeks
and he won in a massacre yesterday
without his top weapons yes I'll buy
that okay who do you think it is Aaron
Rodgers mmm wouldn't it be nice you just
brought teddy bridgewater oh that's even
better I'll take that I'll take Teddy
absolutely Teddy's gonna be the richest
quarterback next year by the way so I'm
glad and and man David you just that was
amazing David it's called false
information that's what that is boss
information yeah which is bad so the
whole time you were like cheesy oh so we
had so many listeners that when I sold
you Kirk Cousins last week hit me up and
they're like I still can't believe I
bought Kirk Cousins so if all people
that are listening right now that's
right you just bought Teddy and you
thought it was Aaron rod we did it we
did no this is this is a good buy for us
not a good - good buys for us jojo's in
Teddy looks good buys you also bought
the Titans defense so you're that was
one little item was one but look Teddy's
been great yeah but anytime you think
you're buying Aaron Rodgers and you buy
Teddy it's not a great
purchase it's a good one oh and I'm
proud of teddy no but it's not a Raj no
he's not Aaron Rogers and there's not a
lot of people in the NFL that are
interruptions however you have a
quarterback for a team that I said here
and told you the Saints are done after
Drew Brees is injuring yeah and he's
come in and played well he's thrown the
ball down the field he looks more
comfortable he's getting the ball to
Mike Thomas they they didn't have Kamara
yesterday I mean they didn't have camara
or Jared Cook no and they move the ball
up and down the Bears no prob one of the
best defenses in the league
well why wouldn't you if they are one
the best they were like where was gonna
say the last two times the Bears have
come out they got pushed around by the
Raiders okay and they got pushed around
by the Saints and I will say two of the
biggest offensive lines in the NFL and
the Bears are missing Hakeem Hicks
that's anything that's looking like it
could be an issue but the thing with the
Saints that's great is I love when teams
lose an important piece and the coach
turns it up a notch right Sean Payton
with that little handoff to the
full-back flick to Taysom Hill was so
nice I look at the Saints right now and
we said when he went down to the Rams we
looked at their calendar and it was at
the Seahawks cowboys bucks at the
Jaguars at the Bears and we send then
Cardinals and we said let's get to the
bye they'll go three and three five and
oh my Super Bowl Saints are looking at
ATS roars or legit every [ __ ] week
but you really believe that Teddy's
earned himself a lot like I saw Peter
King was talking about today he could
see Denver making a play at the end of
solutely Chicago potentially let me ask
you this as a player I don't wanna talk
about money and all that but let's say
you were on a team and you signed Teddy
in the offseason right this kind of a
run what would that do for you as maybe
a future teammate in terms of confidence
with him I would have a lot of
confidence in him because again the same
way this is the reason why Nick Foles
got an opportunity in Jacksonville he
wasn't even went three or four games in
a Super Bowl that doesn't mean he's a
great quarterback they had a good
defense they had a lot of things happen
for him they played at home
and things worked out he got a big
contract in Jacksonville teddy
bridgewater is better than nick foles
you have to believe that sure he's going
to get paid that's why he was the number
one the highest-paid backup in the NFL
this year because he has talent when he
was in Minnesota before the injury he
showed a lot of promise I was not no I
disagree
he had promise you - are you kidding me
he had like a hundred and ten yards
passing in that wild card he was young
he was a young quarterback this is this
is what I mean young quarterback with
promise he was gonna improve and give
you better I said Ryan Tannehill is like
a defensive coordinator dream Teddy
Bridgewater is like a defensive
coordinators wet dream he is so good at
protecting the ball the thing about is
Harry so I that this is what I love
about Teddy and I have been hard and I
want to kind of take some of it back I
got to cover Teddy for three years of
Louisville right and they the rest of
the team talked about Teddy like he was
a magician in terms of one of the most
convincing leaders I've ever seen where
he wasn't a yelling guy but people would
be like he never he gets hurt but he
never tells any of us and when he grew
when he goes to a party it's like that
old draft a thing like no one showed up
to his birthday everyone shows up to
Teddy's birthday everybody likes him I
don't think Teddy's getting a big
contract this offseason he is because I
believe that Teddy's gonna be the future
quarterback of the New Orleans Saints I
said earlier this year that they should
go to Taysom Hill and that was a little
misguided and I think I was a little bit
too excited by the preseason ain't crazy
because Taysom Hill has only thrown
three passes and I don't know how many
more years troubies has left and because
I believe the Saints are gonna win the
Super Bowl this year I think Drew Brees
is gonna go out on top that's just kind
of I think okay let me go my prediction
a little further
I think the Saints are gonna win the
Super Bowl and I think Drew Brees
retires oh yes okay because I don't
think true Brees is gonna want to rehab
any bit more the hand or whatever but I
think if you're the Saints and I go we
know we're gonna have chimera for a few
more years we know we're gonna have
Michael Thomas for a few more years our
offensive line ryan ram chick very young
yes Andrus peat very young Terron
Armstead is getting up there but he's
still pretty healthy we look at our
defense we can build this whole team
with Teddy okay and I think they can
keep Teddy at a pretty good rate because
Teddy is also one of these quarterbacks
that I think if you sit him down in a
room and go Teddy if we pay you eighteen
million a year so like well under
franchise quarterback market value we
can get a lot of studs around you
we got Marshawn Lattimore a stud corner
yeah and I think Teddy will take it I
really do because Teddy had his entire
career flash in front of his eyes
when he was practicing with the with the
Vikings and his bone came out of his leg
and there was a chance he could never
walk again
let alone never play again I see Teddy
now as appreciative of the opportunities
in and I think Teddy also knows because
he played for Mike Zimmer who does not
care about offense at all yeah and then
he went and he sat in the Jets
organization for a year with Todd Bowles
and he was like they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're he's a guy right and then
he went into Sean Payton and Drew Brees
and he saw the relationship that they
have and he also Sean Payton is the top
three offensive coordinator in the
league right now okay I think that
there's a chance that Teddy goes I'm not
gonna get better than this and the
Saints are going [ __ ] we can do it with
Teddy
I think Teddy's staying I think that
sounds ridiculous and I'll tell you why
why would why do we always talk about
dag you'll never get better than what
you have here you have Zeke and you have
all these different things and but
things are going great for you counting
more it's doing a great job in in Teddy
well it sounds like the black
quarterback has to take our hometown
discount so that I'm so there so they
they can stay where they're at know if
you're Teddy you've waited this long I
don't know how old he is thirty years
old or so now he go get paid if the if
the if the Saints aren't willing to pay
you to 18 million dollars hy made up a
fake number okay Bridgewater is 26 26
that's even better
this even means more money for him no
you paid a kid you pay him the going
rate the saying they were dad did the
going rates gonna be thirty four thirty
five million dollars that's the going
rate of starting
quarterbacks in the NFL that's what
you're gonna have to pay ticket you just
made my wish shadow lie witnessed
quarter has it has it has has has drew
brees taking less no that's why the team
was average for all those years
he didn't take less why do we Teddy have
to take less and everybody else takes
more it takes go gets go gets paid
because he wants to stay with Sean
Payton you were if you were gonna rank
all the quarterbacks in the NFL right
now where would you put Teddy I probably
would be in the top half Oh give me the
top half easily so I was on Mina Qaeda's
podcast I had a rag Kamal and I have
Teddy at 21st really ok ok I'll read you
mine yeah I have Phillip Rivers at 20th
I have Jimmy Garoppolo at 19th ahead of
whenever you say from Jimmy G nothing ok
you haven't seen anything from him all
season I have a also above teddy I have
Baker Sam darn old Josh Alan Kyler
Murray I've Kirk Cousins I would have
you saved from Baker Jack where are you
getting this from wherever you say from
these guys listen you ever seen anything
you like if you want to exist in a world
where we give quarterback wins as a
meaningful statistic as though Teddy
Bridgewater like this sense that's a
most important statistic really cuz I
believe that the win is absolutely I
believe that the Saints were able to
shut down the Bears without putting a
single eight-man box on the field and
that since week three the Saints dfangs
ranks third in Win Probability added
behind only the Patriots and the Niners
they shut down the Bears they held the
jaguars to six points they Teddy played
great against the Bucks
they held the Cowboys to 10 if you
believe that the only reason the Saints
are winning is because of Teddy
Bridgewater then you're you should be
his agent because what I'm telling you
is the Saints defense has put Teddy
Bridgewater in a position to win games
yeah and Teddy Bridgewater in my mind is
not more talented than Baker he is not
more talented he is a very smart
football player that has talent well I
think he's I think he could be a really
good quarterback in this league but he
is not in Dax level like dak is a thirty
five million dollar a year guy
Teddy Bridgewater's not because NASA
played enough
he's been hurt he's been a backup he's
been a backup in Minnesota because of
the injury a backup it
jet he's been a backup the last time
here the starter with the Vikings yeah
then he got hurt right yes and then he
was a backup yes New York right yes you
are a GN how much if and Teddy came to
you and said I want to be in the top
quarterbacks paid in the year and you're
the Denver Broncos well how much would
you pay him you have to pay the going
rate you would you can't pay a kid
twenty million dollars look look you
can't want Teddy to get paid I am an
advocate for players first and four but
a French before you even go there
how do you take away the intangibles of
a quarterback and say that there are
meaningless those are important things
all the things that we're talking about
Baker in particular leading the team and
and not worrying about the media all
these important things show that Teddy
does very well what do you think the
bolsters are valuable
what would the Browns record be with
Teddy instead of Baker do you think
you'd be that much better
I think if the way that that Baker's
thrown interceptions absolutely
then who's more who is more valuable
who's better Sean Payton or Freddie
kitchens Sean Payton more about by a lot
right yeah okay who's who's better how
is the is the gap between Sean Payton
and Freddie kitchen bigger or smaller
than the gap between Teddy Bridgewater
and Baker Mayfield that to me feels like
negligible like it's it's not even that
big of a deal right right right in the
media until Baker is saying all these
crazy things in the media and not
playing well in the game until Teddy
goes out there and does it the right way
all those people at the party all those
people following him because he's a good
leader then he goes out there and plays
well this is the guy that you wanted
that's it this is a type of guy that you
want in a destined sure if you wanted
that's in someone that does all the
talking they can't back it up in the
game then you go ahead and do that yeah
and then you'll see your team two and
four but this guy right here teddy
he's one that's why you invest in this
type of guy I understand what you're
saying
the reason the sales team is that one
the coaches of Sean Payton maybe maybe
well how do you draw the line between
Sean Payton and Drew Brees and Sean
Payton and Teddy Bridgewater
there has to be in line somewhere you
have to still go out on the field and
perform Teddy does that because I
believe in all of the sports in May at
major sports in America
hmm the NFL coach
and the coaching staff is the most
result is the most direct correlation to
wins of any sports maybe an MBA coach
can be a big deal not that much major
stars can control that guys right but
there's a reason why Belichick wins
every year and Sean Payton wins every
year and these great coaching staffs can
win every year
Sean McVeigh will find a way to win
almost every year yeah when you have it
when you have a Hall of Fame quarterback
it makes it easy for the Saints to win
and for the Patriots to win it makes it
makes it much easier when you have that
Belichick is when one without Brady Sean
Payton is currently winning without Drew
Brees one wet with operating he went 11
wins without Brady in that one season
and then I don't think any other coach
he didn't have to deal with it again
yeah I mean are you saying what I'm
saying yeah he's running it's also in
the weakest division in football
everybody knows that yeah I mean what
you talk about all right so you're gonna
say you're down to pay I'm a little bit
angry at you the angry at you - I'm a
little angry at you this is the first
time that we've got angry at that race
[ __ ] on I'm not saying that your
race is what I'm say you were joking
about I don't think that your race about
you know that but I think that why why
would we be talking about Teddy taking
less yes so he can stay in the waters
with Sean Payton that because that means
to me that he doesn't have the ability
to be successful in any other office and
that's not true
I'm telling you that I think that if you
put Teddy on to most offenses I don't
think they're gonna be that let me sell
let's go let's go through the team so he
will be as good as Beauchamp if if Teddy
Bridgewater went to another team with a
good offensive coordinator and an
offensive line he's going to be good San
Francisco for example that's the best
offensive coordinator in the NFL okay
well you'll forgive me geez better than
him
yes and Jimmy G hasn't played better
than Teddy oh that's very even like I
like you have to understand like if I'm
doing quarterback rankings and you're
separated by two people hmm it's
negligible well you said he's the best
so he should have higher he should be
better
sure San Francisco should be better I
think that if Teddy wasn't saying Cisco
will be pretty similar to what we're
seeing right now Jimmy Garoppolo it'd be
like even I think you'd be that much
I think it would be better I think it'll
be better okay thing me better I think
Jimmy G has been average yeah I think
he's my agree and I think that I also
think when I mean when I haven't looked
at his numbers but I will now that seven
seven seven touchdowns and six
interceptions that's below average when
I look at two games in the last o three
games in the last seven under a hundred
and under a hundred and eighty yards
passing higher than 181 that's a verage
I mean we're talk about average
quarterback absolutely the best
offensive coordinator so we happen to be
comparing him to Teddy Teddy has been
better
sure so I mean he should be better based
upon your assessment sure because he has
a best office I don't look if if you
want to go based on statistics against
teams that are not even the same teams
that they've faced and not factoring the
other things I get it yeah what really
struck a chord the 49ers have faced
Tampa Bay Cincinnati Pittsburgh and
Cleveland so I mean in Washington by the
way so I mean because I was gonna get
into Aaron Rodgers off of that game but
it kind of got into this really heavier
you got me excited about but I still
[ __ ] love you I love you too man okay
good but we have we have to be able to
discuss anything absolutely no now I'm
just gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you and
the rest of them well you would have
happened you know so we go there but
what happened was yeah I'm still I have
some residual anger
tell me built up and we hit it all out
for the Eagles not not from you but you
know what that's very fair residual
because I almost I almost bumped into
somebody on purpose on the train today
absolutely because of the [ __ ] Eagles
so really that segment was brought to
you by the [ __ ] Eagles damn right
[ __ ] yourselves
what do you do lock you what are you
doing alright Aaron Rodgers that was
godlike flow out of Aaron Rodgers
yesterday yes
Ingeborg said this before the show he
goes it's fun to watch Rodgers cook and
I would say out of really all the
quarterbacks in the NFL
there is a few that if they start
[ __ ] going it's special
Russell Wilson yeah when he starts
dicing you up it's special to Sean
Watson when it's one of those like 45
point Texans game it's great but when
Aaron Rodgers does it it's
the other team it looks helpless he's
looking at the sidelines he's winking
he's doing double Joe guns there
everything he does that that he runs to
the endzone and just kind of flips the
ball and it was cool because this guy
robbed a mouse key of ESPN interviewed
all the Packers that have never played
with Aaron Rodgers before and what it
was like for them because everybody else
goes oh it's there and we see it all the
time but the rookies were like it's like
electing genka start to come into the
huddle and see when he's feeling it like
that it was so cool and all that and
it's it just shows you this Packers team
now six and one is scary bro because
their defense has moments where they're
punching the ball out and the offense
they didn't have Davante Adams
both of their number two and three wide
receivers Allison and mvs were banged up
yeah Jimmy Graham is still playing well
Aaron Jones is actually catching balls
the Packers it was beautiful man well
this is what we've been waiting for all
season long for Aaron Rodgers and that
Matt Lafleur offense to kind of get in
sync at some point you had to believe it
was gonna happen when you have a
quarterback that good you also have an
offensive coordinator head coach that's
saying I'm gonna help you I'm gonna put
some pieces around you
I'm gonna make this thing winnable so
that you don't have to carry the load
and I think finally Aaron Rodgers gave
enough of himself to say okay cool I
don't have to carry too low which he's
been doing his entire career yeah and so
he's like okay well I kind of like not
having to carry the whole load and
things just got easier for him he was
like the basketball player they make
this a dis analogy when you just
shooting in the rim looks like a hula
hoop it's like shooting catching fish in
a barrel and he is that special arm
talent-wise to be able to dice up and
dissect any defense in the league but
when he's on 80% completions yesterday
it's just hard to do that also to put it
in a perspective about this slow start -
Aaron Rodgers hmm when you look back and
you realize that the first three games
of the year yeah we're at the Bears when
the Bears were healthy and ready to go
right Minnesota Vikings Denver Broncos
and we look at those three and go those
are three of the toughest most physical
defense is the NFL we go no crap they
started slow but that's always been the
thing with Green Bay is the fact that
they were able to eke out wins in all of
those games and they're not sitting here
today at 4 & 2 they're sitting here at 6
& 1 it even more incredible no
interceptions in those three tough games
literally no interceptions
who was that calling man man I think
this is it's like a telemarketer yeah
they'd be calling all the time yeah hey
mr. left key yeah no they'll keep
calling for different numbers but no no
interceptions no three games it was
incredible he has finally figured it out
and I'm happy for the NFL because now we
could just see one of the best unarmed
talent quarterbacks jive with the office
of course sad though alright was this
Sunday night could have been special
because it's Packers at Chiefs mm-hmm
and we're not gonna and it was gonna be
Rogers at Chiefs so it would have been
the Chiefs let's say they win still by
twenty or thirty with mahomes of he
stayed and then Rogers throwing sick
having six total touchdowns Sunday night
would have been really really special
the lead-up to that would have been oh
all the tighten the different types of
commercials and advertisers came all
offices it would be nice and the fact
that we don't but I will say this about
Aaron Rodgers his schedule does not get
that much easier he does get Washington
and the Giants a little bit later but
it's Chiefs Chargers Panthers Niners and
then Bears Vikings Lions and they'll
have to keep winning because I think the
Vikings are right on their heels I might
be right on their heels and then if
you're trying to get home-field
advantage
the Niners and Seahawks they're not
slowing down and look the Panthers are
foreign to yes and they could come out
of nowhere
yes Kyle Allen has been playing out of
his mind obviously McCaffrey has helped
him out there but that defense is played
way I would take Teddy Bridgewater for
Kyle Allen you as you should
yes you should good job there all right
so now we're gonna try a new game we'll
see if we can create more anger this one
is called jinx game and I don't know if
there's any rules in the in the
disembodied voice I'll explain it if not
so it's time for our new game the jinx
game hello everybody and welcome to
America's favorite game
show jinkx game the rules are simple
I asked a question and then give a
countdown of three to one
after I say one you shout out your
answers at the same time if you both say
the same thing
you win 1 million Reese's Cups Oakland
and peanut butter a match made in heaven
all right then let's play that hurts my
heart question number one who is the
most frustrating team in the NFL right
now let's hear those answers in three
two one
these largers hmm you know I had to go
my team I'm still upset about that but I
I agree with the charges so much talent
Hall of Fame quarterback in rivers you
get Melvin Gordon pack fumbling on the
doggone gold line yeah I'm not sure the
wide receivers Mike Williams looks like
he's heard all the dogs sometime you got
another great receiver and Keenan Daly's
pulling up falling off just a bit I'm
not sure what's going on with that
football team and I thought they were a
defensive team I thought they were a
nasty aggressive defensive team and
maybe they're not I was I was I did not
have the Chargers making the playoffs
and the main reason was I saw all their
offseason injuries and it's only gotten
worse yesterday they lost Casey Heyward
for a little bit more as to lamp in
offensive lineman that they needed to
come in because of other offensive line
injuries and Thomas Davis I look at this
team and they had to go through all
those weeks of Melvin Gordon holding out
and then he comes in and they're
force-feeding him carries when he's not
even the best running back on his own
team so he they met he messed up the
flow oh it's so bad I mean Austin Eckler
was not only the best running back on
that team Austin Eckler was a top five
running back this year he was every time
I looked it up he was breaking 50-yard
touchdown runs some owners of him on
fantasy football can attest to this but
also yesterday they're down let me check
my notes here they're down at one point
23 213 they're down 10 points late into
the fourth quarter
what happens austin Eckler stutter step
on a corner 41 yard touchdown then they
get the ball back
Austin heckler slant across the middle
20 yards and they think he scores tackle
on the one and what do we do think we
put in Melvin Gordon pick him up the
only reason you're
in the game is because of Austin Eklund
stop force-feeding it to me that's like
a coach that's like if we win our game
winning touchdown with Melvin Gordon
we're gonna look amazing he comes back
the families in here together
do not test the football gods like that
just give the ball to Austin Eckler and
then also they're so talented Keenan
Allen Mike Williams Melvin Gordon Austin
Eckler hunter Henry is healthy he looks
good Melvin Ingram Joey Bosa but it's
been the injuries it's the the Derwin
James as they that's right and and and
you know they're starting left tackle
Russell Oh khumba Ingram to me the
Chargers are the most frustrating team
in the NFL they've been this way for so
many years and I I feel bad for the
Chargers fans because I believe it stems
from the top I look at their owner Dean
Spanos and I go this is the energy
you've created doesn't like to spend
money doesn't spend money is not paying
for the new stadium the public is having
to pay for it their old stadium was the
worst place ever
he never bowels down to hold out seem
and he never like helps out the team
he's moving the franchise he moved it
from San Diego to LA none of the fan
base has come for me they barely have an
analytics department they're always
getting hurt I
it's an owner thing for me you know that
Eckler thing it bothers me because I've
had it happen to me a bunch okay you
drive the team all the way down there
and then here comes the big back listen
just leave me in the game you mentioned
something two football gods listen when
I get us down there don't take me out
I've had that conversation with Marty
morning several times I yo don't take me
out the game was it contentious or did
he understand he understood but they are
the numbers the numbers say get the guy
out is 250 pounds and get the guy that's
230 in not the small guy what you don't
understand in these situations myself
like Austin Texas mall guys you'll never
see him you can't see him the big guys
are not jumping over the top but you all
know if Melvin Gordon's in the game
you're going downhill that's the defense
knows it too Austin Eckler it could be a
lot of different things it could be a
soft mini it could be a song it could be
a catch it give me a
different things gonna be fake out of
the backfield and hit him in the flat so
many different things that defense has
to think about you put the big guys in
there
the defense think about one thing yeah
stopping the run it back right up the
middle it just also seems like a very
egotistical thing to go we're gonna be
bigger and stronger than you you know
exactly what we're doing coming right to
your face let me tell you about and I go
like this I go if if there's a limited
space a limited space and I need the
best cutter to make that quick decision
I would rather have the smaller quicker
guys yeah also as warren sharp wrote in
his book the best way to run the ball in
the red zone is to spread out teams of
course and nobody does it put three wide
receivers out there make them spread out
because if you don't defend them just
throw it quickly and if they do it's
austin Eckler one-on-one with a
linebacker
nobody rather have that you talk about a
hard-headed coaches out and just a quick
Mike Singletary streaks under yeah I do
we are we're like in a Saturday night
meeting and Mike gets going and when we
get down there we're gonna ram it down
their throat and so he said he said he
said you know what coach
every time we get inside the fire we're
gonna run the ball we're never gonna
pass it every play and I'm sitting in
the back like this makes no sense but
you said I'm just gonna tell you right
now we're gonna run it and that's what
we did we didn't score any touchdowns
out of five five five six times yes no
touchdowns cuz you want to run it me
that just doesn't make you say this is
what the coaches yes that's what the
Falcons were doing under Sarkisian then
we get down there and they'd go heavyset
and they'd run and nothing would happen
because unless you're the Colts or the
Cowboys or the Saints and you have one
of these lines you don't have that
little [ __ ] in Italy beat the [ __ ] out
of people stop letting people know what
you're gonna do the I will say that it
felt like the end of the season for the
Chargers yesterday the other two and
five now they are in a division with
Patrick mahomes getting hurt where maybe
they could sneak in there but and the
ASA's read about the Raiders coming back
a little bit - yeah I think the Raiders
I've been very impressed with Gruden and
how they've been able to figure out that
Waller and Josh Jacobs are building
pieces and that's awesome but it also to
me felt
I kind of feel like the Lions had their
season end yesterday for me the fact
that they're now what are they like two
three and one something like that the
Lions right now are two three and one it
was the fact that I'm watching that game
Darius slay gets hurt yeah
carry on gets hurt you know snacks is
getting hurt I'm sitting there going
this team just played on Monday Night
Football
two weeks ago they're hanging in there
with the Chiefs and they get a few calls
that don't go their way then they go and
they play the Green Bay Packers and they
have that game and none of the calls go
their way and then they play Minnesota
and they're getting all these injuries
and Minnesota has a few calls that go
their way again and that late deep ball
to Stefon Diggs and now the [ __ ]
Packers are six and one the Vikings are
five and to Chicago's three and three
and a good and the Lions are two three
and one you're better than Chicago
they're probably a better team that on
Detroit long-term over Chicago but with
two really good teams in the West two
good teams in the south and look at the
lines and I'm like their season it looks
so good
well the Matt Stafford was balling early
on
obviously Marvin Jones got off yesterday
during a tough division they put up 30
points I said yeah that's still
impressive especially for a team that
you're saying is more of a defensive
team but yeah they're a good team wrong
division for their season that's just
the way it go sometimes
man I feel bad for that families all
right let's go back to a jinx game and
see yeah we don't I'm not to be going to
discuss why I'm pissed off about the
Eagle that's well yeah maybe maybe later
question number two who's been the most
exciting rookies so far this year let's
hear your answers in three two one
Joey Bosa well he's been impressive he
has been very sorry Nick post a [ __ ] I'm
gonna say Joey I got always sir Josh
Jacobs I just I love guys listen this
team in Oakland still has a bunch of
work to do but I love guys that just
come in you haven't heard him say a damn
thing he just goes to work every day's
of volume back and they hand him the
rock when he stiff-armed Adrian oh my
first good in the game I thought he
killed him yeah I thought I mean the
night no Jon Gruden it just a little bit
I know he loves Josh Jacobs just hand
the ball to the big back let his Rumble
down the field let him wear down a
defense and then allow a car just to
throw the ball to Waller as much as he
wants but listen I love it I love the
way he plays he makes a lot of good
lateral cuts he has the speed he has the
power to finish at the end of runs yes
he's the type of building piece that you
want at the running back position he is
really a coach's dream people are gonna
sell on the Raiders and I'm telling you
that you sure are not well cut because
the NFL is a reaction based industry and
so the Raiders are gonna have let up 42
points to the Packers now the Packers
are really good probably the best team
in there so this is how the new cycle is
gonna go this is my prediction today and
tomorrow will be spent a lot about Aaron
Rodgers and all that then who the
Raiders play next when we look really
quick the Oakland Raiders play the
Houston Texans next this is perfect
watch this news in Houston okay people
are gonna be telling you
deshaun Watson it's gonna go off it's
gonna be crazy all that stuff because
the Raiders have had a really bad past
defense yes deshaun Watson might put up
big numbers I'm just saying though he
doesn't have will fuller and if you look
at Deshawn watts and splits with them
without will fuller it's a different
type of team because they don't have
that vertical stretch all that but what
I'm saying is if you look at the Raiders
the Raiders go on a 14-play Drive in the
second quarter
Fausta Moreau touchdown they're up 10 to
7 then the the Packers are driving play
a pass interference in the end zone the
Packers go on an eight-minute 11
play dr2 go up 14 to 10 and then here
come the Raiders derrick karr and Josh
Jacobs and Darren Waller go all the way
down to the one car fumbles out of the
endzone
the Packers drive down make it 20 1 to
10
Packers get the ball to start the second
half drive down
touchdown twenty eight to ten yeah game
over done what you think and so what's
interesting to me is the Raiders were
doing whatever they wanted against a
very good Packers defense and the fact
that it's 20 to 10 and they finished
with 24 so they still scored two
touchdowns and a lot of it was Josh
Jacobs they didn't get a fourth down and
one and they were going for it I still
have faith in this Raiders team I think
that the Texans are a very interesting
matchup but people are going to sell the
Raiders later in the week and I'm
telling you that you should buy them
second best team in the AFC West right
now they have to be I think I would take
him yeah the second best team in the AFC
West I think that they're in a building
process with this team they still got a
bunch of draft picks they'll continue to
get better and listen I couldn't have
said that early on in the season in
training camp I would have been like
yeah this team is gonna implode they
have no chance of being good but there
was something inside of this team in
April actually brought it up while
everyone was saying discounting them and
kind of kick it him to the curb
they were silently building yes quietly
like yeah it's us against the world and
they don't have Abrams and it comes back
yes do not forget they played at
Minnesota at Indy in London at by at
Green Bay at heel teams but also that's
five row games in a runs right so like
wait until this team gets at home and
they they're actually in their beds and
they're not traveling around with travel
medicine and all that crap the rate yeah
Cobo medicine was that I can't imagine
that you're gonna get as good of care on
the road as you would at home yeah like
you're like I think you probably should
I just mind like if you're at home for
two weeks in a row you could probably
use more of the facilities yes I had to
work
last one crouching skin travel nuts oh
wait hold on I did get to go I did get -
I'm sorry Nick Bosa yes let me talk a
little bit about Nick Bosa he has four
sacks this season second on the team
only behind D Ford who's a sack
specialist with four two and a third
eight tackles for loss most on the team
ten Harry's almost twice as much as the
next guy but the thing also is I go I
look at Nick Bosa from the flag-waving
in the Cleveland game he gets the final
sack in the Washington game and slippin
slides across and the rest of the team
does it and that awesome image Jimmy G
is not the leader of this team right now
Richard Sherman is not the best player
on the defense this team right now
is George kid alone offense Nick Bosa on
defense but I look at Nick and he really
feels like this [ __ ] talker in the group
and it's a guy that this defense needed
because Buckner has been ballin but he
Buckner retweets people saying he's
underrated you don't say that or ik
Armstead Salomon Thomas is an incredible
guy that has fought for causes and all
that but Nick Bosa is kind of an [ __ ]
no we all think Nick Bose is kind of an
[ __ ] he's a jerk but he has swagger
and but that's what I think this defense
a jaded absolutely and I think it's
given that unit the fu swag that San
Francisco needed because the offense not
nothing about this team everything is
egalitarian all the running backs touch
it all the receivers get a chance
everybody wins the defense you get a
sack you get a tackle for loss you get
an interception but Nick Bose is the guy
that's like [ __ ] you pay me and I think
it's what the Niners either that's why
I'm so excited about him as a rookie
because who knows where it's gonna go no
I'm not working until you pay me and you
know hopefully everybody because he
seems like the type of guy that's gonna
say yeah you paid me now I want you to
pay my boys too yes that's the type of
guy that he seems like oh yeah you paid
me now pay these other guys because the
only way that I'm the person that I am
is because of these guys around Oh pay
the quarterback
you pay everybody all that Trump stuff
scared me but he's grown up yeah you
know ya get the money alright last one
for cheeks game and finally question
number three which NFL teams season will
end most excruciating let's hear your
answers in three two one Dallas Texas
open we're backs in both in Texas yes so
I'll explain first when I thought about
Hollis that's distraint especially out
there last night that's strange to hear
you say that
dude i cygwin others sag that's mom do
you think it's gonna end in the playoffs
regular season I think that typically I
probably answer Saints just because
they've it's they've suffered the most
excruciating in the last two years
Minnesota miracle but I've and then also
last year the pass interference but I
think as I said they're destined for
greatness if I had to think about the
team that would be the most excruciating
like disappointing in the regular season
I would go Chicago because if you look
at their last four games its Dallas at
Green Bay Kansas City at Minnesota so I
think Chicago it's gonna be like it's
gonna be really depressing I think for
bears fence they're not gonna make the
playoffs it's gonna be tough then I
think about the team that might have the
early playoff loss which is excruciating
the embarrassing wildcard loss and the
first one that came to my mind is
Buffalo where Buffalo is that team
that's like 11 and 5 and they're taking
on like a 9 and 7 Houston team and they
put up like six points they can't get it
done school yeah like yeah and that's
excruciating where you're like we're the
better team and then like Josh Allen
throws three picks and you somehow score
nine points that's exceptional but I
look at Dallas as I think it's gonna be
very excruciating because I find them to
be a high-low team that sometimes
they're [ __ ] great and sometimes
they're not and I think that's gonna
continue I don't think that the Eagles
game with the Eagles shitty-ass
secondary Mike is like oh wow the
Cowboys are back know like they put up
that stat last night Amari Cooper
destroys the Eagles as he Prescott
destroy
the Eagles the Eagles are not healthy -
they're not good
and I think Dallas is gonna be that team
that gets in the playoffs and they're
taken on a let's see who are the options
here they're taking on a Minnesota in
Minnesota or they're taking on like a
Carolina and they go there and it's kind
of a dud and then what's gonna be tough
is then they're gonna have to figure out
the dak Amari contracts and that's why
it's gonna be excruciating because
Dallas and Chicago in my mind are in a
very similar thing Chicago has already
paid all of their talent and if they
don't win the Super Bowl this year their
team is going to be destroyed because so
much is going to Khalil Mack and all
those guys Dallas if they don't win it
all this year and they have to pay Daken
Amari yeah I don't know what's gonna
happen to the rest of the team I just
think this is gonna end badly for Dallas
I do not see them as a Super Bowl
contender I see them as a really really
good playoff loser when healthy I think
they I think they have a good team they
haven't been healthy in a long time but
you have to have one of those days where
dak is it's Owen we know that if they
give Z back I had dak by the way where
did you think I had a cracked is my
quarterbacks you want to guess 14 I had
him at 12 12 okay close and I you know
what after yesterday I'd probably have
him in 11 a little bit I oh yeah like
that but but so I'm a little I think
Dallas seasons gonna end really
painfully Dallas I have a feeling your
whole family's going down wow I said I
said Houston a couple different but the
more I think about it I think the Rams
maybe as I ever see that team that that
will crash and burn I could see in the
first round of the playoffs whenever
they play they I think San Fran
obviously wins the division I think yeah
so that means it probably gonna be two
wildcards coming out of that division
you think maybe I don't know we just
talked about the NFC North yeah that's
that's the hard part the playoff picture
it's gonna be crazy it was gonna be so
it certainly we could talk about the
Rams but Houston Texans they
have a lot of talent I mean I love what
the quarterback is done I love the fact
that they got a bunch of receivers on
that team that can just go and get it
speed and can go and get it right Hyde
has done a decent job running the
football they traded every pick that
they can imagine for Tunsil still giving
up sacks by the way with all that being
said they should have easily they should
have been cruising to win that division
losing that game yesterday Mike even
though the quarterback put up good
numbers even though the defense I mean
you know you got to play much better and
I couldn't get to the quarterback but
there's something about this football
team where you're saying you know what
Bill O'Brien is gonna lose him a
football game you talk about it all the
time you you hate the coach he does it
all the time you have to believe that
some point a critical situation build
O'Brien's gonna mess things up no matter
how much talents on that football field
he's gonna mess it up in the worst time
to mess it up is that last couple weeks
of the season
where if you win you're in and if you
don't you go home and that's not awful
lot of talent to be going home so right
now if the season started today the
three six matchup in the AFC would be so
exciting Baltimore Houston ooh I like
that high-scoring I want to say this
quickly about my Baltimore Ravens
because I would say right now to be
proud of them my I would say that I'm
claiming the Saints the NFC and the
Ravens in the AFC but remember before
the year I said that the Ravens would be
the one seat mm-hmm okay right now
they're five and two Kansas City's five
and two as well and they're gonna be
missing my home for the next few weeks
yes I could see them picking up a loss
the Patriots are six no and I would say
they've been very vulnerable they are
their offense has not been great also
their schedule has been wildly easy I am
NOT saying that the Ravens are
definitely gonna make a run of this one
but it's not out of the realm of
possibility that the Patriots could come
back to earth and make it very
interesting with the Baltimore Ravens if
the Ravens can keep up this pace how
impressed were you let you with with
Lamar Jackson aye
Ravens yes so you know here's the thing
there's just not many times in a
football game where you'll say the
quarterback is the best athlete by the
way Patriots play at the Ravens week
nine that's the good it's gonna be a
great game oh so good and I would I
would lean heavily toward the Ravens and
that one just mean that Wow
there there's not a lot of times when
you can say the quarterback is the best
athlete on the field it's just not I
mean because a quarterback usually kind
of stiff you know you gotta buy
receivers that can do all different
types of crazy stuff but Lamar Jackson
continues to show every single game that
he's the best athlete on the field and I
just think that you always wonder you
say I'll give you a sample earlier you
were saying in my mind we're not getting
the best the most out of Aaron Rodgers
just not right I mean just cuz I don't
know that he understands the offense
that well or just him in the for just I
haven't matched up but every time I see
Lamar Jackson I'm saying we got the best
out of Lamar Jackson today every single
time he plays you get the best out of
him whether it's a 150 yards rushing
whether it's only 100 yards receiving
mean passing you're getting the best you
can
out of Lamar Jackson he does things on
the field that make people look silly
that running backs in his league don't
aren't even doing he's that special he
had one run yesterday where he ran out
left I wrote it down
Lamar had so in the fourth quarter and
Mark Andrews has a drop third and eight
Lamar runs for 40 mm hmm the next play
he runs left there are three guys he
takes one step to the right two of them
fall yeah and he goes and picks up yards
and then they go down and get a field
goal make it 23 13 he's just doing
things that other people can't do at the
position and I had him a lot higher than
Mena in the rankings
I had him this is before this last game
I had him at ninth really NFL and you
know with him up higher I would say so I
had him behind Brees the Matt Ryan and
we'll see with Matt Ryan's injuries and
stuff what do you mean so you're just
ranking
I'm just ranking between how they're
playing right now Matt Matt Ryan's
putting up a bunch of yards they're
always trailing he's putting up a bunch
of yards because
domes I also think that if you had to
choose a quarterback to go win you one
game you probably would choose Lamar
Jackson well that's what I mean it's but
look we're in a weird situation because
I've been hyping up Lamar all year yeah
and most other shows have been talking
about how he can't throw and so we're in
this situation where we've actually been
Lamar stands for much of the season and
the rest of the NFL media is starting to
get kids into it that's right and so
it's always weird when like you love a
guy and then other people start loving
the guy and you're like [ __ ] use my
didn't used to like right right and so
Lamar you know the clips are going out
today where John Harbaugh was like do
you want to go for when he goes hell
yeah let's go for and everyone's like I
like this Lamar guy but look I said I
said yesterday and people were like oh
you like his a hundred and fifty yards
and two touchdowns it's just the fact
that if it's third and 15 this happened
yesterday and Lamar steps up in the
pocket to run the opposing fans are
going [ __ ] of course and that's the fear
that Lamar is bringing into people think
about this think about this with the
Ravens as I'm gonna wax more poetic
because they're my [ __ ] team they're
five and two Lamar has not had a great
passing week in the last few weeks his
number one wide receiver has been hurt
for the last three weeks his number one
tight end dropped three balls including
a tight end this week he was doing
yesterday his defense has not had Jimmy
Smith since the first half of the Miami
Dolphins arguably their best corner when
he gets back after this Marcus Peters
trade they could have three corners at
our Jimmy Smith Marcus Peters
and Marlon Humphrey in Boston balling
which means they could now play
man-to-man on the Kansas City Chiefs if
they had to and we don't really have a
wide receiving threat for the Patriots I
just I look at this Ravens team and
Lamar is getting more and more
comfortable every year when the
first-year quarterbacks go to the second
year we see a jump and I would say so
far this year
Josh Allen has made a jump he's been
more accurate on slants Sam Darnell
Sam darn 'old we've seen in Dallas look
like he made a job better yeah Baker
Mayfield
enough took that step back but Lamar has
taken a leap and there are times where
in the offseason we do whoa big
offseason and and we kind of you know
react but Lamar was the whoa big
offseason all offseason we can't believe
how much more accurate is we can't
believe how much better he's throwing
the ball and people spent all offseason
going this is [ __ ]
and it hasn't and he came out to he
threw the ball well early on and these
last three weeks he's been running the
ball a lot more a lot more opportunities
the one position you can never account
for that's why Vic has had so much
success
you can never account for the
quarterback running the football you
just can't your defenses aren't built
that way and you have a week to prepare
for this guy and you get out there you
just can never account for him running
the football and then when he gets his
face he's just better than everybody
else that's huge I want to say I want to
mention one thing though I know Seattle
lost his football game yes it was a
close game I still have a bunch of
confidence in the Seahawks I do too
obviously they gave up two touchdowns on
the offensive side of the ball the
interception in the in a fumble recovery
there for a touchdown
yeah with Humphries they lose about
fourteen points I still think that the
Ravens I'm assuming the Seahawks are
gonna be a tough out for any team that
has to go to Seattle and win even though
the Ravens put up a bunch listen it's
hard to play against this type it's kind
of like you know those teams that you
know when the big schools goes and plays
at Army and Navy and they run the Wing T
and the the wishbone it's hard to
prepare for that you could never prepare
for the speed you can have as many
running quarterbacks as you weren't
running around practice you can't
compare know the type of speed and
prepare for the type of speed that Lamar
Jackson has it's amazing 116 rushing
yards against Seattle 152 against
Cincinnati 70 against Pittsburgh yet 66
against Cleveland 46 and a touchdown
against Kansas City a hundred and twenty
against Arizona Lamar right now is on
pace to have a higher I think Peter King
put it he beat me he has more rushing
yards than I think Zeke that's me
something crazy like there's more
rushing yards and Alvin Kamara and a
better completion percentage than like
Patrick Mahoney the
CERN will always be with running
quarterbacks what if he does just take
that one hit he's really sweating it
he's been great at it that's why I say
he's the best athlete on the field I'll
tell you this
sometimes the best athlete finds that
one person that's just as good as him
that's the part that I'm concerned about
it has to be one of John Harbaugh was
concerned what happens when you found
that one person that gets you just
enough to ding you a little bit and now
you're not running as fast as you used
to I'll say this Ravens have a bye and
their first week after the bye I already
told you New England Patriots we're
gonna see the reason I'm so excited
about that is Belichick IV as I've said
before gives the blueprint but the one
thing that Belichick has an issue with
is mobile quarterbacks November third
eye pops birthday we're gonna learn a
lot about my mom's birthday is November
2nd Wow
yeah look at your dad's birthday August
5th my mom easily mom's birthday is May
5th really would your birthday September
2nd
what about doors have a birthday thank
you May 8th did we become best friends
just now what are those two things of
the day have enough I'll take it yeah
yeah are we okay from earlier I thought
we were very bad yeah okay I don't know
we were bad all the other things you
were mad at me I wasn't mad at you yeah
but I'm over it
yeah I don't really give a [ __ ] I wanted
to yell at you I've just been looking
for the right opportunity
one other note that I want to get in
there is cordarrelle Patterson on pace
to be the best kick returner of all time
he has eight kick return touchdowns yeah
the all-time lead is be devin hester
right kick return touchdown
that's me devin hester is the best kick
returner and soul of all time in terms
of kick return touchdowns Josh Cribbs
and Leon Washington have eight
cordarrelle Patterson has seven and then
Dante Hall had six and Devin Hester had
five but Devin was kick and punt
cordarrelle has done this in six years
Leon did it and eight Josh Cribbs did it
in nine so I but Kourt
has that straight-ahead speed he's never
been that good of a punt returner but
kick returner he can get that full speed
in line to see it's weird because
they're trying to judge basically trying
to get the kick return out of the game
and he still find a ways to do is
amazing no but he's fast
oh and sometimes speed is just better
than anything I've met him now a few
times and I beat him in Madden which was
like a highlight of my life nice a
little bright he's one of the few NFL
players that he walks in and they're
bigger than you think he's gonna be he's
big and he runs straight up to so you
can
he's like a solid 6-3 6-4 230 that's
strange because monster a lot of a lot
of return guys are smaller guys he's
like you're went to Tennessee a physical
freak out of high school we don't know
exactly what he is so we're gonna call
him an athlete right and he's just okay
we're gonna use him a kick returns it's
incredible the amount of talented
players Tennessee has wasted Alvin
Kamara Carroll Patterson we've already
gone very long
I want to talk about the Eagles very
quickly because they're disgusting and
they're not really worth our time I did
say that they would go into the buy at
three and six okay remember that I said
that before
I don't remember three and that's
because I thought that it was this was
when they started off like one in two or
whatever it is and then I thought they'd
get a win over Chicago I still think
they can maybe beat Chicago I think they
will but I don't think that they're
going into Buffalo and winning that game
I'd be a tough game but I also think
that the Eagles are gonna win their last
five games so they got the bills bears
then a bye then they have Patriots
Seahawks then they know beat up and then
I thought they're gonna win those last
five dolphins Giants Washington Dallas
Giants and they win all those so they
end up ten and six you gotta know so I
think if they can beat Chicago and go
into the break with four wins they can
go to nine and seven but they're not
making the playoffs with nine and seven
no not with this and Dallas will still
win
so in and they won't make well here's
the deal about the Eagles in all
offseason long people have said the
deepest roster in football oh it's great
and in and you go into the Dark Horse
season
you'd bring back Jason Peters you bring
back DeSean Jackson you bring back
Darren Sproles you're doing things that
the Patriots the best team over the last
two decades would never do once you've
reached that point you're out and I'm
sorry I gotta cut you we love you we
appreciate what you did here's your ring
here's your pat on the back and you're
out we got to move on to younger and
better players the egos oh we feel bad
let's just you know we'll just keep
these guys here let's keep these guys
here they're part of our winning culture
well guess what comes out today Oh
last week the culture de la creme isn't
that strong anymore with all these
veterans we got someone snitched into
the doggone press talking about the
quarterbacks not checking down the coach
isn't getting it done upset that they
didn't wrap up separate Jhelum Rams
which i think is valid everybody in the
locker room should be upset based on
what they're at secondary has done
offensively you have no rhythm
Frank Wright's gone we can't score in a
doggone first quarter anymore
defensively not only did you not go get
Jalen Ramsey you didn't get Marcus
Peters your secondary has been trashed
the entire dog one season Channel Mills
play pretty well yes he got beat again
yesterday in the first game bang Rasul
Douglas is not a cornerback he's a
safety angry he continues to put him out
there playing cornerback they get beat
in every aspect of the game last time
they paid the dice as a matter of fact
the last three times they played Dallas
Zeke Elliott had over a hundred yards
right guess what he did again last night
over 100 yards rushing and what is that
office that office do now they throw the
ball over the top we can't figure it out
we can't win the big game to me this
team is in a downward spiral with a
bunch of old players and now you pay
your quarterback like he's a franchise
guy and I like Carson Wentz I think he's
okay
he hasn't been special he certainly has
it been the elevator that you're saying
hey we're gonna put some average guys
around him and he's gonna make these
guys better he hasn't made anybody
better he's been okayed at the best now
he has a bunch of guys around him that
that are just okay guys but he has his
job as the offensive MVP of this
football team is to make these guys
better
he hasn't to all the fans that are not
Eagles fans this whole snitching thing
is taking over Philadelphia right now
and they're madam so
xena Anderson had a story where she said
one of the players was complaining about
the quarterback not checking down and
then in a separate tweet about not
training for Jalen Ramsay a media per a
person in Philadelphia Howard eScan
that's been a big name in that city for
a very long time and I never know if
players like him or don't pretty much
said Joe zena's Anderson's source was al
Shawn Jeffrey and out Sean last week
came out and said after they accused him
you know it wasn't that me some notes
and Aguilera said it wasn't me I
wouldn't do that and so there's a team
there's like this Mitch gate thing right
now in Philly which is like that's when
you know it's bad when no one's focusing
on the fact that they're not winning
they're focusing on who's angriest and
they're not winning I mean that can't be
good for a locker room when that's even
a topic of conversation before locker
room because the locker room is about us
together US 53 guys or 47 guys whatever
it is us together versus the world the
Eagles actually made it they want a
Super Bowl based on that the underdog
and it's us against the world and we
don't need all we got is us
they what are you doing when you lose by
27 points on Sunday on national TV Mike
in the most important game of your
season quite honestly you lose by that
amount on national television what the
[ __ ] is gonna be in that like facility
this week like are they gonna come back
like a hundred miles now we're ready to
like go to Buffalo and shock the world
or is it gonna be a little bit of
licking your wounds like is there gonna
be a players only meeting we're sure how
does a team when you get embarrassed
like this how do you bounce back well
well listen again this is what you do if
you were a team leader this is an
important point though this is the most
important game of your season you know
there's gonna be a two-game race in the
NFC East between yourself in Dallas
right and you also know that the loser
of that too that I think Doug woke up
the Cowboys well done said we're gonna
win the game Dallas Cowboys injury
report went from we don't know if either
tackles gonna play any of these wide
receivers and then all of a sudden they
all [ __ ] play well that's what I
think Doug's comments the Cowboys also
had just lost three games in a row and
I'm saying to myself well you know what
we want to go beat a team that hasn't
won in the last three weeks we could do
that is what I'm saying to my football
team and so yeah I
I didn't actually have a problem with
does college like that what that was
meaningless to me here's a deal I just
think that for a football team that has
been through so many wars with these
same guys for them that have to be
dealing with this to be dealing with
inside the room snitches and in in all
those different types of things there's
a lack of culture there's a lack of
character on the football team and
that's gonna be an issue for a long time
because you're you have the leaders in
there you have Peters there yeah that's
why you bring backs pros
that's why you bring back Malcolm
Jenkins who got ran over the led last
night you bring back all these guys so
you these issues you don't have to worry
about I just had a revelation I'm scared
I'm scared ahead we're gonna have the
show right on this let's do it
so the Eagles have lost four games the
only one they lost at home was the
Detroit Lions if you remember right
Detroit had a kick return for a
touchdown that game it did the Eagles
dropped about ten passes and all that
stuff yeah
the other three losses do you know what
they all had in common was that they
were in a dome on turf okay they allowed
24 points to the Falcons they allowed 38
points to the Vikings they allowed 37
points to the Cowboys the Eagles they
got destroyed last season in the
Superdome to the Saints certain teams
are built for certain types of playing
surfaces what the Patriots had done for
years is they get big physical teams
that when you go to Foxborough and you
play them in grass they wear you down
but when the Patriots go to the Saints
it gets kind of scary
when they go to the Lions last year they
lose the Eagles are three um one on
grass there oh and three on turf where
do they win their away game Lambeau
Field the rest of the season they do not
play a game
in a dome or on turf and I'm telling you
they're going to play better the problem
is is when you look at the playoff
picture right now the Saints play in a
dome the Vikings play in a dome like
it's a little bit tricky but I believe
that part of the issue for the Eagles
and tell me if I'm crazy is this is a
big team
that likes to play on grass and they
like to be physical and when they play
speed teams on turf
they look [ __ ] slow and die I haven't
seen a physical Eagles team physical in
the Packers game I thought they are the
Jets that was one game yeah of course
that was literally what's mine ooh
that's really really well I think they
they look they look soft akin up all
their games except for the Packers game
and I think they got beat up in the
trenches offensive and defensive line at
all game except for the pack you know
what
Eagles might going they might beat the
bills in the Bears and I hope I hope
that they can hear this and that they
say you know what screw him we're gonna
prove them wrong I really really do but
they look soft they look like a team
that's not hungry they look like a team
that has no fire underneath there in
their belly and they got up there the
second oldest team in the league so you
got a bunch of veterans on your football
team and you should never go over to a
Sunday night game and get blown up by 27
period and lastly Doug Peterson I just
want to mention this you're down by 27
you got two three minutes left in the
game and you're starting to run drawers
you know what what you should try to do
how much you try to get your offense on
track against the third-string scrubs
that the Dallas Cowboys out there
putting out there how about you try to
get your office on track next week let's
stop running drawers how about you don't
give up on your team how about you do
that because I'll tell you what what
Bill Belichick would have done he
would've been bombing bombs away he
wouldn't be like oh we give up we're
just gonna go over to the locker room
and lick our wounds he ain't saying that
he's saying you know what we're gonna
continue to fight we're called a timeout
even though we don't have a chance to
get in the ball back we're gonna
continue to fight into the whistle sir
to the clock say zero
hmm how about that how about that that's
we're running that was the right hand
got me height man good show today piss
me off today yeah that's good content
all right as long as afterwards we can
kick it and talk about debts ago we're
always going to kill though we're good
on the lef koe man for Brian Westbrook
the Rocket Man people holla holla holla
at you later be well everybody
[Music]